lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
explorar un poco más en nuestro
entendimiento sobre la multiplicación y
solo como un ejemplo usaremos 47 algunos
de ustedes ya saben cuánto es 4 por 7
pero incluso en ese caso pienso que
puedes obtener algo de este vídeo porque
vamos a pensar en cómo puedes expresar
un ejercicio de multiplicación en partes
más sencillas esto no será útil mucho
más allá de 4 por 7 te será útil en el
futuro cuando resuelvas cosas más
complicadas ahora bien hay varias formas
en las que puedes ver 4 por 7 mi forma
favorita es visualizarlo con gatos
enojados así que traigamos algunos gatos
enojados por aquí
[Música]
siguen enojados y puedes ver que esta es
una forma de representar 4 por 7 observa
tenemos cuatro filas cuatro filas y cada
una de esas filas tiene siete gatos lo
puedes ver aquí cada una de esas filas
tiene siete columnas algunos dicen que
esto es una cuadrícula de cuatro por
siete o una formación de cuatro por
siete como quieras verlo
pero si alguien te pregunta cuál es el
número total de gatos será cuatro filas
por siete columnas 4 por 7 otra forma de
representar 4 por 7 es con un diagrama
de barras y se ve algo así aquí estamos
observando 7 veces 4 hoy lo podemos ver
como 4 4 4 44 44 ahora todo esto está
muy bien y si gustas puedes sumar los
pero lo que te prometí son distintas
formas de expresar la multiplicación ya
que esto te simplificar a varias cosas
en el futuro
qué pasaría si no supieras cuánto es 4
por 7 pero imagina que sabes cuánto es 4
por 5 y cuánto es 4 por 2 bueno lo
interesante es que 7 es lo mismo que
cinco más dos qué tal si primero
intentamos averiguar esta cantidad de
gatos en cuatro filas y cinco columnas y
después intentamos averiguar esta otra
cantidad de gatos en cuatro filas y dos
columnas y puedes ver qué es exactamente
el mismo número de gatos una forma de
verlo es que 4 por 7 es lo mismo que
cuatro por y voy a usar paréntesis esto
lo que significa es que voy a hacer esta
parte el primero entonces será 4 por y
en lugar de 7 escribiremos 5 + 2 porque
eso es lo que vale 7
lo único que estoy diciendo es que 4 por
7 es lo mismo que 4 por 52 donde primero
realizamos 52 ya que eso es lo que está
dentro del paréntesis y 5 más dos es en
efecto igual a 7
y podemos ver que esto es equivalente al
número total de gatos que tenemos aquí
que lo podemos ver como la cantidad que
atrapamos de este color anaranjado que
es cuatro filas de cinco columnas que es
lo mismo que cuatro por cinco y a eso le
podemos sumar este segundo grupo de
cabezas de gatos enojados y esto es
cuatro filas de dos columnas es decir
cuatro por dos y podemos poner
paréntesis si queremos para que se vea
un poco más legible ok por qué hice esto
la razón es que algunas personas
encontrarán que 4 por 5 es más sencillo
de encontrar podríamos ir contando de 5
en 5 podríamos ir 5 10 15 20 de igual
manera 4 por 2 es más sencillo de
encontrar entonces parece que es más
fácil decir qué
es simplemente 4 por 5 que es 20 4 por 2
que es 8 así que esto te dará igual a 28
puedes ver que lo mismo sucede aquí
abajo en este diagrama de barras podemos
decir si tenemos 5 veces 4 es justo la
cantidad que tenemos aquí esto es 4 por
el 5 y luego a esto podemos sumarlo con
2 veces 4 el 4 por 2 de aquí esta es
otra forma de obtener 4 por 7 entonces
el panorama general de todo esto incluso
si no estás resolviendo 4 por 7 incluso
si no estás trabajando con gatos
enojados y es que la mayoría de nuestras
vidas
en realidad intentamos evitar a estos
gatos enojados
es que existe una forma de expresar los
números que estás multiplicando en otros
que te pueden ser más familiares te daré
otro ejemplo más imagina que alguien te
pregunta cuánto es 6 por 9 pausa el
vídeo y piensa si puedes expresar estos
números en una forma útil bueno tal vez
sepas cuánto es 6 por 10 y también sabes
cuánto 6 por 1 entonces puedes
reescribir 9 como 10 menos
1 esto significa que 6 por 9 es lo mismo
que 6 por 10 menos 1 con base en lo
mismo que escribir acá arriba entonces
tenemos que esta cosa completa será lo
mismo que 6 por 10
- 6 x 1
una forma de pensar lo será que
distribuye el 6 esta es la propiedad
distributiva 6 por 10 el 66 por 1 de 6 y
tal vez sea más fácil pensar cuánto de
60 menos 6 es igual a 54
yo sé que algunos de ustedes están
pensando que bueno 6 x 9 es muy sencillo
y ahora involucre todos estos símbolos y
escribir todos estos números pero al
final lo que intento es darte las
habilidades para expresar problemas e
incluir formas más sencillas que incluso
podrías hacer en tu cabeza si dices
estoy un poco confundido con el
resultado de 6 x 9 pero sé cuánto es 6
por 10 es 60 y claro que es 6 por 16
entonces qué tal si veo esto como 6 por
10 menos 1
y puedo hacerlo para obtener así 54 una
vez más puede que sepas puede ser
resultado de 6 por 9 o de 4 por 7 pero
en el futuro puede ser que te sea más
útil para números mucho más grandes y
pienses en cómo puedes expresar el
problema